Hello Freak bitches.
That's fish bones.
Yeah,
the Salton Sea.
It's fish bones.
Say what?
No.
The salt and sea is not really a set as the primary cause of the white sand of
Hawaii.
What is it?
Why are we playing games?
Don't hide it's parrot fish.
Yet really?
We're literally going to be walking around on white.
White Sand.
Beaches are made from parrot fish poop.
Oh my God.
I'm so pumped that I taught jewelry and some crazy.
That is insane as possible.
That's in that.
Oh my God.
It just shits like crazy things.
Shit.
Sand.
Oh my God.
It's shit.
Sand.
Does that thing eat like a reef.
What is it?
Eating it at a hunting camp.
Eat Worms.
Sponges and oysters also produced Pacific Ocean stand sand,
but no animal.
This is proficient as the parrot fish
stomachs.
Damn.
Meals past bypass,
like a gastric bypass or someone that has lower
producing as much as 840 pounds of sand per year.
Can you imagine if your poor little asshole had a process yours?
You're a big giant guy of your poor little asshole process.
Eight hundred and 40 pounds of sand per.
Well,
let's break that down.
How many pounds is that a day?
Because 365 days in a year and it's what is.
It's more than double that,
right?
Yeah.
What would a 40 pounds.
So that is more than two pounds of sand through your asshole every day for a
year.
That's insanity.
Now that you're a fish.
So think of that.
It's not even a person.
It's a fish.
A little fish.
It's pumping out more than two pounds of sand through its tiny little asshole
every day.
That's insane.
There's never been a thing like this.
Yeah.
And instead they dig their heels in and get confirmation bias from all these
other people.
And then they formed these social media groups,
facebook groups,
they go to websites,
they get on web forums and they started interacting with each other and
exclusively interacted with each other.
And then also in forcing each other's beliefs and.
And great job man.
Good job of attacking those shills right?
You know those,
like if you do know,
if you think the earth is round,
you were at globe tarred.
That's the newest.
Jamie literally like cringed.
He took them head.
I had to like step back.
Blink his eyes.
Yeah.
You're a globe toward,
uh,
that,
that whole thing is because these people,
someone said something that someone wants.
Look,
people love to finance secrets.
They love the dinosaur thing is cool because it seems to be real and suddenly
see the gal that said that,
uh,
all the fossils were basically people doing like kind of Michelangelo deal and
Chiseling the matter rock because the fossils came out of rock.
Oh,
you got in?
She actually what?
She has been pretty nice boobs too.
But yeah,
maybe that's why people are listening,
but it's like I've got a platform now.
You've gotten tits.
No,
it's really good.
I mean,
yeah.
So she's basically like,
okay,
so these things come out of rocks.
So these anthropologists,
because there's millions of dollars in anthropology or archeology there just
chiseling these bones out of rock.
And here we go into her
fossils that are found in the ground.
You don't want to play games against dinosaurs.
I wouldn't need to play some of this.
Okay.
I'm a little bit about the composition and composition,
what they end up being when everything is said and done.
Um,
so,
uh,
fossil,
fossil is actually a bone that was once in the ground that has been filled with
limestone,
calcium and other kinds of stone link deposits over the course of many,
many years left eyes at a patch of the day looking like,
why is she doing that?
What's your fucking hair out of your rock this big?
And you say,
okay,
there's a bunch of fossils.
Can you hand the rock off?
So paleontologist,
the paleontologist takes a little mallet and they chip away at it and at some
point they come out with something looking like a bomb and this is a problem.
Hold on,
this is a problem.
Just pause that.
The problem is some fucking idiot.
Like this gets to talk about a subject that she's not educated in and no one is
over her shoulder got,
that's not true.
That's not true.
It's strange.
You said something that I want to go back to.
Like what,
what do you think feminism is about?
What's his argument about?
About equality?
I mean,
to me,
feminism was about equality and I think that this,
this,
you know,
I'm reading more about it and learning more about it,
so I'm still very ignorant about it,
but there's more third wave,
what they call third wave feminism,
which I'm sure is a term you've heard that seems to be more about a combative
nature to actually,
you know,
instead of like saying like men and women are equal,
men and women should deserve the same rights in the same treatment and all those
kinds of things.
It's actually seems to be very anti man in a way.
Like it seems to be very,
like almost like the tables have turned and I'm like,
but why are you turning the tables like we didn't you achieve what you want in
like in the first place,
which was just that we were going to be here together at the,
at the,
at the nexus of everything as two genders.
Part of the problem is that reinforcing that fake statistic,
the gender pay gap that so many people have heard that,
like Sarah Silverman was just talking about it recently and some,
some big thing that she did.
I'm like,
that's not true,
but yet people just say it and no one stops them from Santa.
A friend of mine,
there's was a very educated guy said it.
We were having a debate about,
um,
a divorce and he brought it up and I'm like,
that's not even true.
And unfortunately in a place with no
cell phone reception,
so I had to wait until we got back to send it to them.
Like,
this is not true.
Like what you're saying is not true.
Like you're repeating it as if you know,
but meanwhile you've done zero research on it.
It's a talking point that just gets reiterated over and over again without any
research.
And it's convenient.
It's convenient to reinforce your argument.
It's a number.
It's a number that deals with a very complex and nuanced debate.
And I think that the idea of feminism is to me in a lot of ways,
very similar to the idea of the men's rights movement.
I'm not opposed to rights for anybody.
I'm not opposed to anyone.
I'm very egalitarianism ideas about the world,
but I am opposed to anybody that likes one gender over the other because I think
that's foolish.
Just like I'm opposed to people that only like white people.
I'm to put pose to people that only like black people.
I'm opposed to people that generalize based on an enormous mass of human beings.
Like men are shit,
women rule,
girls rule,
boys drool,
you know,
I,
I don't like it the other way either.
I don't like it that he man,
woman haters club I don't like.
I don't like any ideologies that lump people into these huge groups because I
think it's more on think.
I think it's a stupid way of looking at the world.
But we have started water towers.
So basically we drill a well and then we have a water tower which turns into a
water kiosk where people from the community come up to it.
They might pay pay five shillings for Jerry,
so jerry cans,
five gallons,
they pay five cents,
but eventually all the people in the community,
the one that Rwanda we're doing,
it's going to serve 4,000 people.
It's at a school so the kids will have clean water all throughout the day,
but then people come there and the one in Kenya is funding a school,
but the one in Rwanda is going to fund more water wells.
So as these people by clean water,
the only clean water around there,
that community,
the only thing they have to drink,
there's a lake that has the cows and everything else drinking out of it.
Cow patties are inside the water
and you can see people collecting water at the same time that cows are drinking
from it right beside them.
People are washing clothes in it,
they're watching motorcycles in it.
Um,
and then that's their drinking water.
And so we're putting up this water kiosk where yeah,
we're going to charge them five cents when they get five gallons of clean water,
but those are going to turn it into multiple water wells throughout the year.
And so we're trying to do all these sustainable solutions to where after we do
that in Rwanda,
we're taking that to the Congo,
there'll be close to the soa production facility in the community development
center.
We're going to have,
which will have land,
water,
food solutions,
um,
even the forestry we felt to replant over 4,000 trees in the Congo.
And it's like,
because of deforestation,
so brutal.
So I think it's just sitting back and saying,
what do you guys need?
Listening and learning that need and saying,
okay,
where can we fit in?
How can we help in this area?
Who is a specialist?
How can we really make an impact?
I think our lane is definitely water.
I mean from that chiefly Omi village or the story that you just saw,
the bofi where he made that knife where you,
um,
you can see that water changes everything.
And so that's going to be what hubs,
that's our hub,
that's,
that's our lane.
And that's what all of the water teams are doing.
But in the Congo,
because of the pygmies are so vulnerable,
we're trying to find the ways to help them come up.
And as they come up,
other people are watching and looking and they're starting to implement the same
kind of things.